they're making Republicans I don't know
how they're doing it it's I had a family
member who isn't who's a boomer and a
die-hard liberal and they told me when I
was home this Summer that they would
vote for DeSantis and I'm like how did
you lose this person I know how they did
it you know how they did it they would
not stop with the woke stuff the
Liberals would not defend liberalism you
don't want uh your kids second grade
teacher talking to them about chopping
their genitals off if you want your kids
to be taught that America is actually
fundamentally decent and how about we
have an honest assessment of what our
founding is and what our history is well
you could do that in certain red States
but it's getting increasingly harder and
harder to do in blue States